[Music]
holy ps+ Batman here we go again Sony
have unveiled the PlayStation Plus games
for September 2019 remember though we
cannot download these into the first
Tuesday of the month ok that's September
the 3rd so if you're ready for this it's
a damn good month let's do this
first up is the simply sublime Batman
Arkham Knight the final chapter in
Rocksteady's take on the Caped Crusader
first released back in 2015 if you
played any of the Arkham series you know
how great the action feels taking on
numerous foes without seemingly breaking
a sweat but there is more than mindless
button bashing here timing and knowledge
of your surroundings are needed to
perfect the free-flowing fisticuffs in
terms of story Batman is back in Gotham
taking on scarecrow the Joker and many
other marquee bad guys but this time
around his Batmobile is here which is
almost the main character in this outing
with exploration action scenes and
puzzles taking Batman's ride into
account
I mean it's straight up turns into a
tank on command it's really weird but in
a nice way
it gives missions variety an average
player will take about 13 hours to get
through this one but those side quests
they could take you another 20 hours not
because they're hard just because
there's so many of them then on top of
that we have challenge maps and good
hold New Game+ the reviews have Batman
Arkham Knight range from about 7 to a
perfect 10 out of 10 are you going to
download it who the hell am I kidding
course you are next up is another great
game which I beg you to try this is
Darksiders 3 from late 2018 it isn't
even a year old yet
you play as fury one of the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse
following a war between the angels and
demons you are sent to claim the seven
deadly sins if you played the other
games you know how great the lore is in
the dark side the series ultimately
Darksiders 3 is a hack and slash game at
its core but there is more than just
simple button bashing again
understanding the weaknesses of each
enemy is vital to defeating them quickly
and preventing them from overwhelming
you and that's where the RPG element
comes in we are able to upgrade our
character such as weapons which are
integral to process further into the
game URI has multiple attacks to master
but you'll quickly discover which are
your favorites and rarely change unless
forced and just when you getting
comfortable
Darksiders 3 throws a boss at you and
they are out for blood you are going to
die multiple times in that way it feels
like a Souls born game there are some
puzzles too just in case I'm making this
seem like it's combat focused but guess
what it really is combat focused so
there we have it what are you feeling
about PS Plus this month happy sad
delighted mad let me know your thoughts
if you got this far in the video by the
way right Batman is the best Marvel
character and lets stress out some comic
book fans together sounds good I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade no one gets
this far so I could say anything about
now I think Mario would win an arm
wrestling match with Sonic what do you
think so yeah